welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing psilocybin psilocybin is a
psychedelic meaning it modifies the
psyche and in doing so it changes our
level of Consciousness psychedelics such
as psilocybin change the way that we
perceive the outside world and our
internal World our memories our thoughts
our feelings Etc not just while one is
under the influence of psilocybin but it
can also fundamentally change all of
those things afterwards and for a very
long period of time afterwards as well
which is one of the reasons why there's
growing excitement about the application
of psilocybin and other psychedelics for
the treatment of various mental health
issues such as depression alcohol abuse
disorder and addictions of various kinds
as well as things like OCD and eating
disorders today we will discuss
psilocybin talking about what it is in
fact you may be surprised to learn that
psilocybin basically is serotonin now
for those of you that are familiar with
psilocybin serotonin you might think
wait that's not true but in fact
psilocybin's main effect is to mimic
serotonin but it does it in a very
specific way because it activates a
subset of Serotonin receptors in a very
strong fashion leading to
neuroplasticity at the level of the
neural circuits that is the brain areas
and the connections that serve things
like memory and perception so if any of
that is confusing at this point I
promise to make it all clear in just a
few minutes
psilocybin is one of many psychedelics
of course there are things like LSD DMT
5meo DMT even MDMA while not considered
a classic psychedelic is considered a
psychedelic in the general sense today's
episode is going to focus on psilocybin
in particular I will tell you what
psilocybin is how it works at the
molecular and cellular level I'll talk
about how it changes brain circuitry
I'll talk about the clinical effects
what's been demonstrated in controlled
laboratory studies I'll talk about
dosages and translating from psilocybin
mushrooms to actual psilocybin and the
compound that actually exerts the
effects of psilocybin which it turns out
is not psilocybin but something called
silosin silosin is the actual compound
that goes into the brain to create all
the changes in Consciousness and all the
rewiring effects that we associate with
psilocybin so understanding how
psilocybin is converted to silacin has
tremendous impact on the duration of a
psilocybin Journey whether or not that
psilocybin and journey is going to lead
to a short or longer window for
neuroplasticity in fact many people
don't realize this but much of the
positive changes that are possible with
proper and I do want to underscore
proper psilocybin therapeutic approaches
takes place after the session in which
one feels all the you know typical or
typically Associated effects of
psilocybin like hallucinations and
changes in thought patterns Etc so today
we are going to talk a little bit about
chemistry but I promise to make it
accessible to anyone and everyone
regardless of whether or not you have a
background in chemistry or biology we're
going to talk about some cell biology
the actual neuronal changes
that occur when one takes psilocybin and
we're going to talk about how neural
circuits change over time and how all of
that impacts the changes that most
people are interested in when they go on
a psilocybin Journey things such as
long-standing improvements in mood
things such as tremendous insight into
themselves and to others into their past
their present and their future and even
changes in their levels of creativity or
their ability to experience Joy from
music or their ability to dissociate in
a positive way from things that formerly
were depressing or triggers for
depression in fact we're going to talk
quite a lot about the conditions inside
of a psilocybin Journey that make it
actually positive and therapeutic this
is a very important point that I'll make
several times throughout today's episode
which is that just because something
invokes neuroplasticity changes in brain
circuitry does not mean that it's
therapeutic or I should say does not
necessarily really mean that it's
therapeutic for neuroplasticity to be
therapeutic it has to be adaptive it has
to allow someone to function better in
life than they did previously so today
we will talk about how the conditions of
a psilocybin Journey including whether
or not it's done with eyes closed or
eyes open or whether or not people
alternate between eyes closed and eyes
open phases of that Journey as well as
whether or not music is played during
that journey and even what types of
music are played Will dictate whether or
not somebody will feel better or worse
in the days and weeks and years
following that psilocybin Journey as
well as the dosage level because as
you'll soon learn as well there are
clinical studies showing that just one
psilocybin Journey can improve mood in a
long-standing way but most clinical
trials involve two dosages spaced in
very precise ways from one another with
appropriate follow-up but in both of
those particular Journeys the structure
of the journey who's present who's not
isn't eyes open or eyes closed the
particular music that's played all of
those features make up part of a larger
neuroplasticity trigger of which
psilocybin is critical but psilocybin is
not the only variable so whether or not
you're interested in participating in a
clinical study or whether or not you're
interested in psilocybin for other
reasons this is critical information to
understand so today we're going to talk
about nearly every feature of psilocybin
possible including
what psilocybin is how it works at the
level of chemistry cell biology and
neural networks and neuroplasticity
we'll talk about the clinical studies
we'll talk about dosages we will talk
about conditions of clinical studies and
we will talk about the post-silocybin
journey period in which neuroplasticity
and the various activities including
therapy or perhaps not therapy
can contribute to positive therapeutic
changes from psilocybin now as we go
into this discussion I do want to
underscore the fact that at the time of
recording this episode meaning now may
psilocybin is still a schedule one drug
it is considered illegal in the United
States there's perhaps just one
exception to that maybe a few others but
the main exception is in the state of
Oregon psilocybin has been approved in
particular therapeutic settings for use
in particular conditions namely
depression and some forms of addiction
so in Oregon it's more or less in the
domain of a decriminalized as opposed to
actually legal in other areas of the
country including Oakland California
there's some areas in which it has been
decriminalized and perhaps there are a
few others that I'm not aware of but in
general psilocybin and other
psychedelics are still considered
illegal and this is very important not
just saying this to protect me I'm
saying this to protect you possessing or
certainly selling psilocybin except for
rare instances such as clinical studies
and these decriminalized areas that I
talked about a moment ago is still very
much not allowed under the law today
I'll also discuss safety issues I'll
talk about whether or not young people
meaning people 25 or younger should
consider psilocybin given that their
brain is still in a rampant period of
naturally occurring neuroplasticity
I will also talk about dosages as it
relates to people who have formerly been
on or may currently be on different
forms of antidepressants and I will talk
about people who are at risk for
psychotic episodes either because they
know they themselves have a propensity
for psychosis or they have close family
members who have psychosis which
includes things like schizophrenia
bipolar depression as well as things
like borderline personality and some
related psychiatric conditions so
today's episode really will be a deep
dive into psilocybin so whether or not
you think you're already familiar with
psilocybin and its effects or whether or
not you're just curious about them I do
encourage if you're willing to try and
Ratchet through some of the
understanding of how psilocybin works
and what it is leading up to some of the
therapeutic applications and different
patterns of dosing
spacing of different sessions Etc
because I do believe that with that
knowledge in hand you will be able to
make far better much more informed
decisions about whether or not
psilocybin is right for you before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
eight sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity now sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance everything goes
far better when we are sleeping well on
a consistent basis and one of the key
things to getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that the temperature of
your sleeping environment is correct in
fact your body temperature has to drop
by one to three degrees in order to fall
asleep and stay deeply asleep and waking
up involves a heating up of your body by
about one to three degrees with eight
sleep you can program your mattress to
be a specific temperature at the
beginning middle and towards the end of
your sleep night ever since I started
sleeping on an eight sleep mattress I've
slept far better than I ever have so
it's an all-around great tool that has
tremendous functionality not just for
measuring but for improving your sleep
if you'd like to try eight sleep you can
go to eightsleep.com huberman and save
150 off their pod 3 cover eight sleep
currently ships in the USA Canada UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
Roca Roca makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are the absolute highest
quality I've spent a lifetime working on
the biology the visual system I can tell
you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
challenges in order to make sure that
you can see clearly under any conditions
Roka understands all of that and has
designed their eyeglasses and sunglasses
so that regardless of whether or not
you're in a very brightly lit area or a
more shady area or you go from brightly
lit to shady areas you can always see
with tremendous clarity now even though
they were initially designed for sport
Roka glasses and sunglasses come in a
tremendous number of different
Aesthetics so they have the kind of what
I call cyborg versions that most people
associate with Triathlon glasses and
sports related glasses but they also
have a tremendous number of frames that
you feel perfectly comfortable wearing
to work or out to dinner Etc if you'd
like to try Roca eyeglasses and
sunglasses you can go to Roka that's
roka.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20 off your first order again
that's Roca roka.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's episode is
also brought To Us by hvmn Ketone IQ
Ketone IQ is a ketone supplement that
increases blood ketones now I know most
people are familiar or at least have
heard of the so-called ketogenic diet
which is essentially a very low
carbohydrate diet it's designed to get
your brain and body functioning off
ketones which are a great source of fuel
for the body and brain however most
people including myself are not
ketogenic that is I'm not in a ketosis
State pretty much ever as far as I know
nonetheless with Ketone IQ you can
increase your your blood ketones and
thereby improve things like cognition
and physical performance I find that
when taking Ketone IQ even if I'm eating
a standard omnivore diet which is the
diet that I follow by taking Ketone IQ
prior to workouts sometimes on an empty
stomach and especially prior to doing
any kind of cognitive work so
researching podcasts or doing work
related to my lab or teaching Etc that I
can maintain mental Clarity for a longer
period of time and it does seem to
enhance my mental clarity as well if
you'd like to try Ketone IQ you can go
to hvmn.com and use the code huberman to
get 20 off again that's hvmn.com and use
the code huberman to get 20 off let's
talk about psilocybin and again today
we're going to focus specifically on
psilocybin and we're going to set aside
all the other psychedelics for future
episodes
psilocybin is what's called a tryptamine
that refers to its chemical composition
not to the so-called psychedelic trip in
fact it's spelled differently tryptamine
is t-r-y-p trip TR IP of course
tryptamines include psilocybin but also
things like DMT and 5mao DMT the
tryptamine psychedelics very closely
resemble serotonin itself that's right
most of you have probably heard of the
chemical serotonin and serotonin is
what's called a neuromodulator which
means your brain and body naturally make
it and that it modifies or changes the
activity of other neurons and neural
circuits and it does that generally by
either increasing or decreasing the
activity of those neural circuits if I
were to show you a picture of the
chemical structure of psilocybin or its
active derivative silosin and I were to
also put right alongside it an image of
the chemical structure of Serotonin
provided that you weren't a chemist who
really likes to focus on the detailed
differences between things you would say
those look very similar and indeed
psilocybin and its active form silosin
are very similar structurally and
chemically to serotonin itself now as I
mentioned before serotonin is something
that you naturally make and yes it's
true that about 90 percent of the
serotonin in your brain and body is
manufactured in your gut however
contrary to popular belief
the serotonin in your brain is not
manufactured from the serotonin in your
gut you have separate independent
sources of Serotonin that is you have
particular neurons that make serotonin
in your brain you also have serotonin in
your gut and those work more or less in
parallel separately
now what does serotonin do this is
really important to understand because
of the similarity between psilocybin and
its actin form silacin and serotonin
serotonin
in that it's a neuromodulator changes
the activity of other neurons and the
net effects of those changes are things
that you're familiar with for instance
satiety or the feeling that we've had
enough of various things such as food or
a social interaction or sex or pleasure
of any kind serotonin is involved in all
of that and an enormous number of other
things such as mood regulation such as
our sense of pleasure itself or lack of
pleasure such as whether or not we feel
motivated or not motivated it works in
concert with other neuromodulators such
as dopamine and epinephrine and
norepinephrine in fact if this were an
episode about serotonin which it is not
you would soon realize that serotonin is
involved in so many different functions
that impact our daily life
and that is one reason why certain
antidepressant medications which alter
either increase or decrease the amount
of Serotonin Transmission in the brain
will often have a lot of side effects
related to things like mood libido
appetite sleep Etc it's because
serotonin is involved in so many
different things and serotonin is
involved in so many different things
because there are a lot of different
so-called serotonin receptors serotonin
is a chemical that we call a ligand and
the chemical ligand is simply the thing
that plugs into the receptor for that
chemical or ligand The receptors in this
case serotonin receptors have the
opportunity to do all sorts of different
things they can change the activity of
neurons making them more active or less
active they can cause growth factors to
be released making sure that those
neurons reinforce or even build up
stronger connections so that they're
more likely to be active in the future
serotonin binding to particular
receptors can even change the gene
expression in particular cells making
those cells proliferate so make more of
them making those cells more robust
making those cells interact with new
elements of the brain and body basically
serotonin and all these different
receptors that it binds to has dozens if
not hundreds and maybe even thousands of
different functions
so the fact that psilocybin so closely
resembles serotonin leads to a very
important question that we should all be
asking ourselves which is why is it that
psilocybin which looks so much like
serotonin when one takes it in the form
of magic mushrooms or some other form
maybe the synthetic form of psilocybin
itself which nowadays is manufactured in
Laboratories and placed in different
psilocybin containing foods and pills
Etc
why that leads to complex yet fairly
circumscribed sets of experience like
Visual and auditory hallucinations
changes in particular thought patterns
and neuroplasticity that in many cases
in the clinical setting provided things
are done correctly
improvements in mood relief from
depression relief from various
compulsive disorders Etc right this is
really what you need to understand if
you want to understand psilocybin and
how it works and how to make it work
optimally for a given condition or goal
you have to understand what it's
actually doing and what allows
psilocybin to do fairly specific things
in comparison to serotonin even though
psilocybin and serotonin are so similar
is that psilocybin mainly binds to and
activates the so-called serotonin 2A
receptor the serotonin 2A receptor is
one of again many different serotonin
receptors but serotonin 2A is expressed
in particular areas of the brain and
even on particular areas of neurons in
the brain that allow for very specific
types of changes in neural circuitry to
take place not just when one is under
the influence of psilocybin but
afterwards as well so really in order to
have a useful discussion about
psilocybin we need to talk a lot about
the serotonin 2A receptor but you know
fortunately for you unless you're
somebody really interested in structural
biology or cell biology that discussion
is not going to be about The Binding
pocket for serotonin on serotonin 2A
receptor or a lot of the downstream
signaling of the serotonin 2A receptor
we'll talk a little bit about that where
it's relevant but more importantly at
least for sake of today's discussion
we're going to talk about how the
serotonin 2A receptor is really the one
responsible for triggering all the
changes in neural circuitry that lead to
the changes that is the improvements in
mood the relief from compulsive
disorders in many cases but really it's
the serotonin 2A receptor selectivity of
psilocybin that is leading to all the
excitement that you hear about in terms
of psilocybin as a therapeutic tool
let me say that from a slightly
different angle
there are data that I'll talk about
today which show that
one although in most cases two
psilocybin Journeys done with particular
dosages of psilocybin lead to maximal
binding or occupancy of those serotonin
2A receptors in ways that lead to
significant and unprecedented relief for
major depression in fact you'll soon
learn that the clinical trials for
psilocybin are outperforming standard
therapy and outperforming so-called
ssris and various other antidepressants
in terms of providing depression relief
in ways that are
frankly staggering not just to me but to
the psychiatric community at large and
this is where so much of the excitement
is coming from Now that statement could
be taken one way which is to just say
okay well here's a compound psilocybin
that outperforms ssris and therefore all
the attention should be on psilocybin
but
SSRI stands for Selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor in other words the
ssris of which there is now a lot of
controversy things like Prozac Zoloft
Etc I'm sure you've heard some of this
controversy there are people who are
very Pro ssris although they're a
growing number of people who really feel
that the ssris are probably most
appropriate for things like
obsessive-compulsive disorder where they
in fact can be very beneficial but
there's a lot of kind of leaning back
from ssris as the be-all end-all for the
treatment of depression nowadays because
of the side effect profiles and the fact
that it's not even really clear that
serotonin deficiencies are the major
cause of depression in the first place
now again we're talking about psilocybin
not about ssris but you should be
thinking wait how is it that two
molecules
psilocybin and some particular SSRI both
of which look like and or increase
serotonin Transmission in the brain are
leading to either incredibly positive
and interesting outcomes or to kind of
troubling side effect riddled outcomes
and again it all boils back down to the
selectivity of psilocybin to bind that
serotonin 2A receptor and so in order to
understand how psilocybin works and in
order to understand proper dosing
profiles and spacing of sessions AKA
Journeys we really need to talk a little
bit more about the serotonin 2A receptor
where it is in the brain what sorts of
things happen when psilocybin binds the
serotonin to a receptor and how those
things set in motion the various changes
the neuroplasticity that allows people
to feel better in terms of their mood
and as you'll soon learn can experience
more pleasure and Joy from things like
music and enhanced creativity all the
things that I do believe whether or not
people are thinking about or maybe even
exploring I've been for recreational or
therapeutic purposes all the things that
people want and are really talking about
and perhaps even doing psilocybin in
order to obtain so before going any
further I just want to place an image in
your mind you can place an image in your
mind whereby when serotonin is released
in the brain naturally not having taken
any compound any drug anything
it's getting released at a lot of
different sites binding to a lot of
different serotonin receptors doing a
lot of different things
when somebody takes an SSRI the net
effect of that selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor is that there's more
serotonin around to exert its effects
because it's a reuptake inhibitor at the
synapse the connections between neurons
the serotonin can do its thing more
extensively and for longer periods of
time but it's doing it kind of
non-specifically so when you think about
standard
antidepressant treatments at least for
sake of this discussion you kind of
think of a sprinkling or a kind of you
know spraying of Serotonin at different
locations in the brain and binding to
lots of different receptors
whereas when you think about psilocybin
even though the subjective effects are
pretty diverse we'll talk about those in
a few moments
what you're really talking about is a
molecule psilocybin that looks a lot
like serotonin that is selectively and
very strongly binding to and activating
that serotonin 2A receptor so that's the
image I'd like you to embed in your mind
and then the next image I'd like you to
embed in your mind is wear these
serotonin 2A receptors are located in
the brain
now the serotonin 2A receptors are
located in multiple brain regions
but they have a tremendous amount of
expression in the so-called neocortex
the outside of the brain that includes
things like our prefrontal cortex which
is involved in understanding context
right which behaviors thoughts and you
know speech patterns are appropriate for
certain circumstances
um how to switch context and category
switch when you go from you know playing
sports to hang out with friends to being
in a professional setting you change
your behavior in the way that you speak
and perhaps even the way that you think
you might think some things that are out
of context but you probably keep those
to yourself and your ability to keep
those to yourself are dependent on a
functional prefrontal cortex there are a
lot of 5ht 2A and by the way 5ht is the
abbreviation for serotonin so there are
a lot of Serotonin 2A receptors in the
prefrontal cortex also in other areas of
the cortex that are associated with
sensation and perception that is hearing
of sounds that is seeing of particular
things and in particular there is a very
very very high expression of Sarah tone
and 2A receptors in the visual cortex
and that is one of the reasons why
psilocybin triggers visual
hallucinations and provided psilocybin
is present at sufficient enough
concentration that is taken at a
sufficient dosage
one will experience profound visual
hallucinations regardless of whether or
not
their eyes are open or their eyes are
closed
now that's an important fact because it
explains one of the major effects of
psilocybin that people experience while
they are on the drug
now as I'll talk about a little bit
later in terms of what constitutes a
useful psilocybin session useful meaning
that it's leading to Adaptive
improvements in mood adaptive
improvements in creativity and cognition
Etc
is that people not have their eyes open
for at least the majority of the
psilocybin session this is something
I've discussed with several experts who
are running clinical studies on
psilocybin in their Laboratories some of
whom are going to be guests on the
huberman Lab podcast in upcoming
episodes
and I can't underscore this enough
because your visual cortex contains so
many of these serotonin 2A receptors and
because psilocybin binds so strongly to
that serotonin 2A receptor you're going
to experience a lot of visual
hallucinations when you are under the
influence of psilocybin there's no
surprise there this has been known for
hundreds if not thousands of years it's
one of the main reasons why people take
psilocybin however as I mentioned
earlier these hallucinations occur even
when the eyes are closed and it's now
fairly well established that if people
are to take psilocybin and have their
eyes open much of their cognition much
of their thinking much of the time spent
in that psilocybin Journey
is focused on the altered perceptions of
things in the outside environment
sometimes this looks like a sort of a
fracturing of the outside world into
kind of geometric shapes sometimes it
appears as a kind of melting of things
in the visual environment including
people's faces or a morphing of people's
faces all of that has a strong let's
just call it a draw for a lot of people
who are looking for a highly unusual
experience inside of the psilocybin
Journey but I think if one's goal is to
derive the long lasting benefit from the
psilocybin experience it's very clear
that having an eye mask or some other
eye covering or something that ensures
that one's eyes are closed for the
majority if not the entire psilocybin
session
is going to be very useful because it's
going to limit the extent to which one
is focused on those outside changes in
visual perception AK hallucinations and
rather will allow the person to go
inward to combine whatever it is that
they happen to be seeing in their Mind's
Eye with the different thoughts and
memories and changes in their emotions
that are occurring and that going inward
by staying in the eye mask at least for
the majority of the time it seems to be
a very if not the critical feature of
making the psilocybin Journey effective
in the therapeutic sense now once again
I want to cue to some of the safety
precautions here I'm going to say this
at least three times throughout today's
episode as I'm talking now and various
other times throughout today's episode
you may get the impression that I'm all
for everybody doing psilocybin and that
is simply not the case in order for a
psilocybin journey to be therapeutically
useful it does require certain
conditions and supports and there are
certain people for which psilocybin use
is going to be contraindicated meaning
they should not do psilocybin in
particular people who have existing or
have a predisposition to psychotic
episodes or bipolar episodes even having
a first relative who has bipolar or
schizophrenic or schizotypal issues
can be a rule out condition that is can
get someone eliminated from a clinical
study on psilocybin for fear of
triggering psychotic episodes not just
during the psilocybin Journey but
potentially in a long-standing way so
again that's really critical the other
thing is that everything I'm talking
about today unless I say otherwise is
really focused on adults meaning people
who are 25 years old or older that is
their basic wiring and rewiring of the
brain that we call developmental
neuroplasticity is completed all right
most of the studies today that I'll talk
about involve subjects ranging from 25
years of age out to about 70 years of
age but no one younger so again
psilocybin and its use is certainly not
for everybody it's still illegal it's
being used in the clinical setting and
research setting they're these pockets
of decriminalized areas and potentially
suing legalization of psilocybin but
again only in the proper clinical
setting okay again I say that not just
to protect myself but I say that also to
protect all of you psilocybin is a
powerful powerful drug not just to be
under the influence of but also in terms
of its long-standing changes after the
effects of psilocybin have worn off I'd
like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag-1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 let's
talk a little bit about dosing of
psilocybin and also about microdosing of
psilocybin now this is an area that I
wouldn't say is controversial but that
there's uh how should we say this
there's a lot of
um loose thinking around this in the
non-clinical non-research communities
but within the clinical and research
communities there's a lot of data that's
come out indicating what effective and
safe doses provided all other things are
considered safe safe doses of psilocybin
actually are and here we really can go
back to our discussion of psilocybin as
quote unquote magic mushrooms or
mushrooms and if one were to translate
from the mushroom form of psilocybin to
the psilocybin that's actually used in
various studies because frankly in these
studies people aren't eating mushrooms
they're typically taking synthetic
psilocybin either intravenously injected
into a vein or orally
and that's how the researchers are able
to tightly control the amount of
psilocybin and the typical dosage that's
used in clinical studies ranges from one
milligram
often given repeatedly from day to day
over long periods of time so-called
micro dosing and really that one
milligram per day or even up to three
milligrams per day repeatedly over time
is what people generally think of as
microdosing as compared to say a 10
milligram dose given once maybe twice in
two separate sessions or a 25 to 30
milligram dosage that's given once or
twice now those amounts of one to three
milligrams or ten milligrams or 25 to 30
milligrams might not mean much to those
of you that don't think about these
things in the research terms perhaps
you've heard of microdosing and you've
also heard of
macro or quote-unquote heroic dosing
okay that sort of a common uh or I
should say popular nomenclature for
psychedelics and I'll Circle back to
that in a few minutes but I think one of
the questions that I hear a lot is how
much psilocybin is present in a given
amount of mushrooms and so the way this
typically works is that mushrooms are
often discussed in terms of grams or
ounces so an eighth of mushrooms refers
to an eighth of an ounce of mushrooms or
X number of grams of mushrooms
the breakdown is actually quite simple
one thousand milligrams equals one gram
and the concentration of psilocybin in
most so-called magic mushrooms is about
one percent so one gram of mushrooms
being 1 000 milligrams means that it
contains approximately again it's
approximately
10 milligrams of psilocybin and in most
of the clinical studies it's been shown
that the dosage of 25 to 30 milligrams
given or I should say taken once or
twice we'll talk about the spacing of
sessions a little bit later Taken once
or twice
is what's leading to the most pronounced
therapeutic outcomes but of course
with enhanced therapeutic outcomes one
also observes enhanced side effect
profiles or what are called Adverse
Events so there's an important nuanced
conversation that has to take place but
right now we're talking about the
conversion of grams of mushrooms to
psilocybin so one gram of mushrooms
being one thousand milligrams
containing one percent psilocybin
means that it contains 10 milligrams of
psilocybin now the so-called heroic
doses that you've heard about and this
is something that's discussed more with
the let's call them traditional or
classic Psychonauts these are people
that may have an advanced degree but
typically are not running Laboratories
exploring the effects of psilocybin in
controlled clinical trials
these are people who um have been long
time explorers and often writers and
people who have been spokespeople for
psilocybin and other psychedelics and
they will often refer to the so-called
heroic doses it's a little bit hard to
translate from that informal Community
to the scientific data but in discussing
that topic with various researchers who
run Laboratories at major universities
focused on psychedelic Therapies
what I was told is that the
quote-unquote heroic dose that's often
discussed really refers to a 5 gram or
so dose of mushrooms so what that
translates to is 50 milligrams of
psilocybin so when you hear someone talk
about a quote-unquote heroic dose
they're probably referring to ingestion
of 50 milligrams or so of psilocybin but
in its mushroom form so about five grams
of mushrooms and again it's important to
point out that the concentration of
psilocybin in different strains of
mushrooms and in different batches and
depending on the age of those mushrooms
and how they've been stored Etc can vary
tremendously from batch to batch in fact
there are some Laboratories that have
explored the range of psilocybin
concentration in different mushroom
strains
different so-called magic mushrooms and
that range is pretty broad it's anywhere
from a half percent all the way up to
two percent what that means is that
someone might get a hold of one gram of
mushrooms thinking that they're taking
10 milligrams of psilocybin in those
mushrooms when in fact they're actually
taking 20. or somebody could take three
grams of mushrooms thinking they're
taking 30 grams of psilocybin and in
fact they're only taking 10 or 15
milligrams of psilocybin so the sourcing
is really key obviously as Things become
more legal and more regulated and more
used in the therapeutic setting or and
this is what's happening more and more
or as people start to rely on
synthetically made psilocybin as opposed
to using mushrooms to ingest psilocybin
then certainly the dosaging is going to
be more consistent from batch to batch
because we're not talking about batches
of mushrooms we're talking about batches
of psilocybin itself so now I'd like to
take a step back from all this chemistry
and cell biology and talk a little bit
about the structure of a psilocybin
Journey itself and relate that to what
we now know about what's happening in
the brain during the psilocybin journey
and then a little bit later we will
return to that serotonin 2A receptor
when we talk about some of the more
lasting changes in brain chemistry and
brain wiring that occur after the
psilocybin journey is over
so let's take a couple of minutes and
just discuss the various components of
an effective therapeutic psilocybin
journey and here I'm not detailing a
menu of things that people should do in
order to pretend that they are a
psilocybin assisted therapy coach or to
do self-administered psilocybin therapy
that is not what I'm doing what I am
trying to do is to share with you the
consistent components that are present
in the clinical trials that have
demonstrated the effectiveness of
psilocybin for the treatment of
depression and for other compulsive and
addictive disorders and those data
meaning the specific data related to
those trials and the references
themselves we'll get into a little bit
later but we can't really have a
conversation about psilocybin and what
it does without talking about the
so-called set and setting as it's often
referred to
that is known to at least bias the
probability of the journey being
beneficial and not a so-called bad trip
so what are the variables that make up
an effective and safe psilocybin journey
and again when we say safe we're
referring to people who are not prone to
psychotic episodes that don't even have
a first relative that's prone to
psychotic episodes
we're talking about people that are 25
years or older we're talking about
people that for instance are not taking
antidepressants that impact the
serotonin system this is very important
to understand I think a lot of people
don't know this but as far as I know all
of the studies that have explored
psilocybin for its ability to positively
impact brain chemistry and mood and
function have required that people
either not be on or abstain from
antidepressants in the weeks leading up
to the psilocybin Journey now that is
not to say that if you are currently
taking ssris or something similar that
you should cease taking them and do
psilocybin I'm absolutely not saying
that that could be very very very
dangerous if not catastrophic anytime
you're going to take anything or stop
taking anything for that matter you do
need to consult with your physician this
case a psychiatrist as well so let's
talk about psilocybin Journeys from the
subjective side and from the structural
side and when I say the structural side
what I mean is what does a psychedelic
Journey actually include and here are
the words set and setting become
extremely important some of you may have
heard that set and setting are the
foundation of a well done or even
therapeutically beneficial psychedelic
journey and all of that really hinges on
safety and outcomes so set refers to
mindset the mindset of the person taking
the Psychedelic and setting refers to as
the name suggests the setting in which
they're taking it in and the people that
are present there so let's talk about
setting first the setting for a
psychedelic Journey needs to be one in
which the person under the influence of
the psilocybin or other psychedelic is
safe that means no windows they can jump
out of that means no streets of moving
cars they can run out into that means no
opportunity for getting lost that means
no opportunity for getting into bodies
of water
in other words it requires that there be
at least one and perhaps even two or
more other individuals who are not also
taking psychedelics right who are not
also taking psychedelics present
in that setting to ensure that the
person taking the psilocybin is not
going to harm themselves or others I say
this not to sound like a school teacher
even though technically I'm a school
teacher
but because of course I don't want
anyone to get harmed and I'm also aware
that there's a lot of interest nowadays
in psychedelics such as psilocybin
becoming legal or decriminalized for
their therapeutic applications
and if we look back to the late 1960s
and early 1970s when the Controlled
Substances Act was invoked to make
psychedelics like psilocybin illegal one
of the bases for that was not just the
geopolitical unrest at the time and
things like the Vietnam War but also
some highlighted instances in which
people did not take set in setting into
consideration took things like LSD
stared at the sun went blind or took
psilocybin went out and harmed somebody
else again these are very very isolated
instances but these are the exact sort
of instances that lead to
criminalization or the fact that things
like psilocybin and LSD and MDMA for
that matter are considered illegal again
I completely acknowledge that there are
a number of different factors making
them illegal we could have a whole
discussion about that
um we talk about the drug trade the War
on Drugs but right now is such a
critical time in the history and the use
of psychedelics for therapeutic and
other reasons and getting setting
correct meaning making it absolutely as
safe as possible for the person taking
the Psychedelic is absolutely key and
one of the best ways to ensure that it's
safe is to have responsible individuals
who are not under the influence of
psychedelics present in that environment
so that's one component of setting the
other component of setting that we
talked about earlier which turns out to
be very important is the opportunity and
perhaps even the bias toward the person
on the Psychedelic being
seated or ideally lying down and being
in the eye mask or at least having their
eyes covered so that they can combine
any spontaneous visual hallucinations
that occur with the various thought
processes that are occurring while under
the influence of psychedelics
this is Far and Away different than
quote unquote taking mushrooms and going
into the woods or taking mushrooms and
going to the beach what we're talking
about today is the use of psychedelics
for a particular brain rewiring outcomes
that yes can involve things like
changing one's relationship to Nature
we're changing one's relationship to
somebody else by interacting with nature
or somebody else and while I'm not
trying to diminish the potential value
of those sorts of psychedelic Journeys
if we look at the scientific data
the vast majority of it not just in the
clinical setting but in terms of
understanding the safety and efficacy
and positive rewiring of brain circuitry
that allows people to feel better to
understand themselves better and to
interact with life in more adaptive ways
going forward out of the Psychedelic
Journey involve these very let's say
um you know subdued settings that are
typically in one room a closed
environment with one or two other
individuals acting as sort of guides or
helping the individual by talking to
them from time to time if they feel like
they have to sort through a particular
aspect of the Psychedelic Journey that's
creating anxiety and we'll talk about
the Contour of the Psychedelic Journey
that almost everyone who takes
psilocybin at somewhere between 20 and
30 milligram dosages tends to experience
but the setting that I'm describing is
not just a list of things to you know
make sure you're safe but they're really
the list of things that also ensure that
one can get the maximum benefit out of
the psilocybin Journey now other things
included in setting that are known again
from scientific literature to be very
influential in terms of the experience
that one has and to bias things towards
a positive experience are
again safety eye mask but also the
presence of music now when I first heard
about this from one of the Premier
researchers on psilocybin and other
psychedelics which is Robin cardard
Harris he's a professor at University of
California San Francisco who's one of
the major Pioneers in the studies of
psychedelics and when he first started
telling me about the critical role that
music plays I thought okay that makes
sense you know music can impact our
emotion impact
um the way that we think and could
therefore impact what one experiences
during the Psychedelic Journey but he
really underscored for me the extent to
which music is not just a sort of
incidental feature of the setting in
psychedelic set and setting but that it
is one of the but that it is one of the
major drivers of the actual cognitive
and emotional experience that somebody
has on
something like psilocybin that allows
the psilocybin journey to be looked at
or viewed not just as beneficial but and
this is quoted in the scientific
literature as one of the most profound
and important positive experiences that
one ever experienced in their life so
let's talk about the sorts of music that
have been used in these clinical studies
well first of all we need to think about
how long the psilocybin Journey itself
is going to be and the typical duration
of the psilocybin journey is anywhere
from four to six hours it's going to
depend somewhat on dose it's going to
depend somewhat on variability in
people's liver metabolism and it's also
going to depend somewhat on how much
food people have in their gut
in all the clinical studies that I read
it was advised that people not have any
food in their gut at the time in which
they ingest or injected with the
psilocybin it's particularly true if
people are going to be taking psilocybin
mushrooms in order to get their
psilocybin and that has been done in a
few studies most studies however use
synthetic psilocybin taken orally
again that's converted to silacin in the
gut by the acidity of the gut and the
acidity of the gut is going to be
impacted by the various foods that
people eat and so that's one of the
major reasons why people are advised to
not eat for at least four hours prior to
the psilocybin Journey so here we've got
this six hour what we're calling Journey
because that's what everyone calls it or
trip
that people start experiencing about 30
to 45 minutes after ingesting psilocybin
or taking psilocybin there's a peak
component in which there's a maximal
intensity of emotion and often that's
also associated with anxiety and this is
very important to understand the anxiety
component is part of what in the
therapeutic setting they refer to as ego
dissolution and that anxiety around the
peak and I think most people would
probably hear Peak experience and think
oh we're talking about a peak positive
experience
but no we're referring to a peak
experience and anxiety that people
stay with and then come down from
gradually as one goes from the second or
third hour after taking psilocybin and
that tapers off slowly toward the six
hour mark what sometimes people refer to
as parachuting back in
of course um they're not hopefully I
would very much hope people aren't
actually parachuting back in while on
psilocybin but I think you get the idea
the music that's typically played in the
clinical studies using psilocybin for
the treatment of depression or for
compulsive disorders or addiction
tends to have a particular Contour that
matches with and can also drive that
Contour of the psilocybin Journey that I
just described again we're talking about
people wearing an eye mask with guides
present so people who are not taking
psilocybin there as well to ensure that
the person feels supported and is safe
the person is typically lying down
sometimes sitting down but more often
than not lying down wearing an eye mask
and the music that's played at the
beginning of the psilocybin session
tends to be music that doesn't have a
lot of vocalizations it tends to be
things like classical music it tends to
be fairly low volume but that then
transitions into music that has a lot of
percussion so often drums that tends to
be higher volume that has a lot of
intensity
at about the time that one would be
experiencing the peak in emotion and in
perception the so-called peak of the
journey
that intense music tends to be played
for about 45 minutes to 90 minutes
depending on the study one looks at
and then tends to transition into softer
music again
sometimes Coral type or more melodic
music often female voices in particular
and then transition into nature sounds
and things that more or less mimic the
outside natural world and less so
um synthetic things like drums or
instruments and vocalizations and things
of that sort so why would it be so
important that music match and even
contribute to the subjective experience
that people have on psychedelics and
here we should probably take a couple of
moments and just talk about what those
subjective experiences are like so for
people that haven't done psilocybin or
any psychedelics
it's a little hard to describe but one
way to describe it is that there's a lot
of so-called perceptual blending so for
instance people in the eye mask will
report seeing some geometric shapes and
colors but perhaps the music they're
listening to will then start to change
the intensity or the movement of
whatever it is that they're seeing
hallucinating inside of the eye mask in
ways that are linked this is referred to
as synesthesia or the merging of
different senses that are not ordinarily
merged in addition people under the
influence of psilocybin or other
psychedelics for that matter often will
report that their pattern of breathing
becomes linked to the perceptions of
things that they are hearing or seeing
or feeling so for instance if they take
a big deep breath in and then a long
exhale out they may find that during the
long exhale out that the notes of music
that they're hearing in those moments
are also drawn out for the duration of
the breath and they'll inhale and that
they're getting at least what they
perceive as control over the music which
of course they are not actually
controlling by using their breath and
that perhaps their visual perceptions
are also being merged with that so those
are just a couple of examples of how
perceptual blending AKA synesthesia
can occur while under the influence of
psilocybin and this really is highly
individual from one person to the next
some people for instance will find that
if they take their fingertips and rub
them across the couch or the chair that
they happen to be lying down or sitting
on that they will experience a change in
the music maybe even if they you know
they move their hand up they hear an
increase in frequency of sound they move
their hand down they hear a decrease in
frequency of sound and that all of this
is linked to their emotional state at
the same time and vice versa okay so
we're talking about a lot of perceptual
and emotional blending and some sense of
control over one's perceptions and
emotions in a way that's very unordinary
even extraordinary we can step back from
all of this very subjective description
of the Psychedelic journey and ask what
is going on that would allow these sorts
of things to occur and there you are
already equipped with an understanding
of the cell biology and the chemistry
that makes all of this possible and that
is that when psilocybin is ingested and
then converted to silacin and it's the
silacin that crosses the blood-brain
barrier and then even though silacin
looks a lot like serotonin silacin has
this incredible ability to predominantly
activate the serotonin 2A receptor well
we can understand much of what's
happening at a subjective level during
the Psychedelic Journey even right down
to the sorts of emotions and perceptual
blending the synesthesia we can
understand a lot of that by
understanding where the serotonin 2A
receptors are expressed on neurons and
what those particular neurons are doing
and the simplest way to describe this is
that there's a category of neurons that
we call pyramidal neurons pyramidal
neurons are found lots of places in the
brain but they're called pyramidal
neurons because they're shaped like a
pyramid they have a cell body which is
the part of the cell that has the DNA in
it and a lot of other important things
like the organelles mitochondria Etc and
then they also have what are called
dendrites dendrites are the little
branches or processes
that reach out both from the bottom of
these cells and then
these pyramidal cells are interesting
because they also grow a branch up up up
up into layers of neural tissue above
them and they have what's called an
apical Branch that's the part that grows
up and then they fan out at the top and
that Fanning out at the top allows them
to communicate with other neurons in
their environment okay so if you're not
getting a good picture of this in your
mind for my description I apologize but
simply think about
putting your arms out to the side and by
doing that you're able to interact with
things that are some distance from your
body sort of an obvious thing in that
case
these cells are effectively doing the
same thing by extending little processes
out into layers above them and to the
sides and this is really important
because much of the serotonin 2A
receptors that are present on neurons in
the brain are present in those apical
dendrites those branches of these
pyramidal neurons that are above and
that extend out to the side of those
neurons and so when somebody is under
the influence of psilocybin that means
that silosin has bound to The receptors
on those apical dendrites and it's
increasing lateral communication across
brain areas in fact this is perhaps one
of the most well-documented effects of
psilocybin and other psychedelics which
is that there's a shift from the brain
being more modular meaning more
segmented like auditory neurons or
communicating electrically and
chemically largely with other auditory
neurons of course they'll communicate
with other types of neurons too right
when I hear something off to my right
you know like a snap of fingers off to
the right I'll turn my head and my
ability to do that depends on my
auditory neurons being linked up with
things like my motor system and my
visual system but
the key thing to understand is that when
there is psilocybin present in one
system
that the communication of any of these
pyramidal neurons the ones involved in
hearing the ones involved in thinking
the ones involved in memory the ones
involved in visual perception or in the
generation of visual hallucinations with
eyes closed those are all talking to
many many more other neurons
more extensively
so what happens effectively is that
there's a reduction in the modularity
the separateness of function in the
brain and an increase in what's called
integration
of communication across what would
otherwise be disparate brain regions we
can say that really simply by saying
psilocybin increases communication
across the brain
now in addition to that there's a
reduction in What's called the
hierarchical organization of the brain
typically sensory information comes in
from the outside environment so we hear
something we see something we taste
something we smell something
and in what's called bottom-up fashion
meaning bottom from the periphery
up meaning it propagates up Through The
Eyes through the nose through the ears
through the skin
or the senses in those regions I should
say
up into areas of the brain that sit deep
to the cortex like the thalamus
and then the thalamus is sort of a Way
Station it's like a switchboard that
sends visual stuff to the visual centers
and auditory stuff to the auditory
centers and touch stuff to the touch
centers and
things that maybe trigger a memory off
to the memory centers of the brain Etc
that's the typical organization it's
hierarchical because it goes from the
periphery up to the more complex
processing regions of the brain that
make decisions that link all of that
stuff to Prior experience maybe plans
about the future
when psilocybin is present in the system
there is a broadening of the flow of
that information from the bottom up as
well okay and that has to do with what's
called thalamic gating the thalamus is a
very interesting structure we probably
don't want to go into it in too much
detail right now but it really is like a
switchboard in a way station saying hey
pay attention to the visual stuff pay
attention to the auditory stuff or just
to the visual and auditory stuff and
ignore
um you know touch sensation for the time
being or vice versa
when psilocybin is present in the system
and when serotonin 2A receptors are
activated very strongly there's a
tremendous broadening of the flow of
information up and through the thalamus
so not only is there more communication
of so-called higher order brain centers
we refer to them as higher order because
they're involved in thinking and
decision making and emotion Etc but
there's also a shift in the flow of
sensory information into the brain that
can generally be described as a broader
and including more blending of the
different senses and when I say blending
of the senses I'm also referring to
blending of the sense of interception of
our sense of our body and what's
happening inside of our body and this
without question at least partially
explains why
went under the influence of psilocybin
one's breathing can be linked to a sound
and then suddenly the sound
one thinks is being controlled by one's
breathing or that the sound itself can
be linked to something that we see in
our Mind's Eye while in the eye mask
essentially what I'm describing here is
that serotonin 2A receptor activation
allows for more Broad
less precise and less hierarchical
activation of brain circuitry and when I
say hierarchical what I mean is that
normally things go from periphery from
eyes to Thalamus to visual cortex
however when under the influence of
psilocybin as I mentioned before even in
the eye mask the visual cortex is going
to be very activated even in the absence
of any visual input so then if one hears
a sound
perhaps from music
particular Motif for voice and that's
linked to a particular emotional state
that is now being blended with visual
phenomenon occurring within the brain
that have no external stimulus and so
while the patterns of activation in the
brain while under the influence of
psilocybin aren't random they are far
less channeled far less modular and far
less hierarchical than would ever be the
case when not under the influence of
psilocybin I'd like to just take a brief
break and thank one of our sponsors
which is element element is an
electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means plenty of salt sodium magnesium
and potassium the so-called electrolytes
and no sugar now salt magnesium and
potassium are critical to the function
of all the cells in your body in
particular to the function of your nerve
cells also called neurons and we now
know that even slight reductions in
electrolyte concentrations or
dehydration of the body can lead to
deficits in cognitive and physical
performance element contains a science
back to electrolyte ratio of one
thousand milligrams that's one gram of
sodium 200 milligrams of potassium and
60 milligrams of magnesium I typically
drink element first thing in the morning
when I wake up in order to hydrate my
body and make sure I have enough
electrolytes and while I do any kind of
physical training and after physical
training as well especially if I've been
sweating a lot and certainly I drink
element in my water when I'm in the
sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's
lmnt.com huberman to claim a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drink element lmnt.com
huberman now in all fairness to the
scientific literature they're not one
not two not three but four prominent
theories of which brain networks are
most activated during a psilocybin or
other psychedelic journey and so for
those of you that are interested in
those different models first of all
please know that they are not competing
models while some of them disagree about
some of the details it's very likely
that all of these models are true they
include things like changes in the
so-called default mode Network there's a
lot of interest in this I've talked
about it before on this podcast the
default mode Network because the network
in the brain that's thought to be
responsible for spontaneous imagination
for daydreaming and that reflects sort
of the base activation state of the
brain when there's no drugs in our
system and the default mode network is
one of the systems or networks rather
that is thought to be rewired under
conditions of psilocybin or other
psychedelics again if you're interested
in these models and comparing and
contrasting them there's a very nice
review from Brian Roth's Lab at Duke
entitled the neural basis of psychedelic
action we'll provide a link to this in
the show note captions and again I just
want to emphasize that
all of these models have been shown to
be true in different studies and what
they all point to is more extensive
communication between areas of the brain
that normally are not as
active at the same time while under the
influence of psychedelics such as
psilocybin
the controversy in the field relates to
which of these networks is the one that
changes the most to explain the
therapeutic outcomes that have been
discovered in recent years so again
check out that review if you're
interested in that sort of thing in the
meantime we can cut a broad swath
through all of those models and just say
that psilocybin expands the functional
connectivity of the brain while one is
under the influence of psilocybin and it
does seem that some of that expanded
functional connectivity persists after
the effects of psilocybin have worn off
and that statement about the functional
connectivity of the brain being more
expanded not just during the psilocybin
session but after as well has been
substantiated in a number of papers but
one of the key papers in this area is
one that I recommend people check out if
they're interested in this sort of thing
is entitled the effects of psilocybin
and MDMA on between Network resting
state functional connectivity and
healthy volunteers and I like this paper
for a number of reasons first of all
it's a very high quality paper carried
out in the laboratory of Robin cardart
Harris at UCSF again one of the Premier
researchers in this area of psychedelics
and their function what they do in the
brain and also their therapeutic
applications but also because it focuses
on healthy volunteers they explored
using brain Imaging what brain areas are
active in a resting state so things like
default mode Network
then they had people take psilocybin or
MDMA and then they looked at the
connectivity between those brain areas
in those same individuals when they were
not under the influence of these drugs
and found more extensive connectivity
all of which pointed to an enhanced
lateral connectivity less hierarchical
organization effectively more
interconnection and communication
between different brain areas I think
not only is the fact that they looked at
healthy volunteers very interesting and
important but also that they looked at
this resting state of the brain they
weren't providing a particular auditory
or visual stimulus for people to hear or
look at while they were in the brain
Imaging scanner as it's called
rather they were simply looking at how
the brain was behaving at rest and so
it's very clear that for people that do
two or even just one of these psilocybin
Journeys at a particular dose that the
brain is actually getting rewired you
know we hear this a lot
psilocybin or other psychedelics lead to
plasticity they rewire your brain well
let's go back to what we said at the
beginning rewiring of the brain is not
the goal
adaptive rewiring of the brain is the
goal right rewiring that leads to new
ideas that are interesting that are
accessible after the Psychedelic Journey
new ideas and new ways of thinking or
feeling that allow people to function
better in their lives that that's the
goal of effective psychedelic therapies
not simply rewiring of the brain you
know a brain injury for that matter will
lead to rewiring of the brain but that's
maladaptive rewiring the use of things
like amphetamines or methamphetamines in
particular will lead to rewiring of the
brain but that is strongly maladaptive
rewiring so now there are really dozens
of studies conducted in humans using
brain Imaging and other techniques have
evaluated how things like psilocybin
change connectivity in the brain and I
think the take-home message is it
expands that connectivity
however it seems to do so in ways that
still allow people to function in their
daily lives one of the key things that I
glean from the literature on the
therapeutic use of psilocybin for the
treatment of depression
is that very seldom do people who take
psilocybin experience long-term issues
with memory why is that so critical well
you could imagine that increasing
connectivity in the brain reducing
modularity reducing hierarchical
organization of the brain would lead to
disruptions in memory right it's as if
you're shuffling books on the bookshelf
so to speak but that doesn't seem to be
the case rather it seems that the
increase in connectivity is leading
provided set and setting are correct
provided safety Protocols are followed
to positive rewiring or adaptive
rewiring of neural tissue so that's one
of the things that makes psychedelics
and psilocybin in particular very
exciting from the therapeutic standpoint
and of course we have to acknowledge
it's also what has a lot of people
excited about psychedelics not just for
the treatment of depression but for
expanding the brain's capabilities more
generally so along those lines I want to
touch on the issues of creativity and
the experience of life outside of
psychedelic Journeys is impacted by
psychedelic Journeys and here this
relates to a question that I heard a lot
when I put the call out on social media
that I was going to do this episode and
I asked people what do you want to know
about psilocybin and one of the more
common questions that I got was does it
increase creativity does it increase our
experience of life in ways that are
beneficial aside from its now documented
positive effects in treating depression
and compulsive disorders and addiction
and the short answer to this is yes but
that the positive effects of
psychedelics psilocybin in particular on
creativity and our experience of Life
have only been explored in a fairly
narrow set of dimensions
however where it's been explored there's
some really interesting findings so one
of the more interesting findings I think
is a paper entitled increased low
frequency brain responses to music after
psilocybin therapy for depression I
think this is a really interesting paper
because what the authors did is they
took advantage of the fact that in these
therapeutic psilocybin sessions that are
carried out for the treatment of
depression music is being played
and there are prior studies
showing that when music is played you
activate different brain areas depending
on what sort of music is being played
it's somewhat obvious perhaps you know
sad music versus you know intense
um you could think about heavy metal
versus choir music versus Gregorian
chants versus punk rock music and on and
on it makes sense that different brain
areas would be activated when different
patterns of Music are played however
there do seem to be some Universal
features of brain activation in response
to music This should probably be the
topic of an entire episode of The
huberman Lab podcast and indeed it will
be for instance
there are areas of the auditory cortex
that are activated no surprise there and
areas of the brain's reward circuitry
the so-called ventral striatum and the
so-called mesolimbic reward pathway
talked a lot about these in the episodes
about dopamine that I've done previously
these are brain areas that lead to the
release of dopamine in other brain areas
and that reinforce certain experiences
and that tend to give us the subjective
feeling of yes I like this I want more
so in this particular paper
what the authors did is they took
advantage of the fact that
people are in the clinic
they're on psilocybin
they're listening to music and as you
recall the music played at different
stages of the psilocybin Journey are
different they have a different
emotional component and music is a
really nice stimulus in the laboratory
as we say because like with visual
stimuli you can break it down into high
frequency low frequency right sounds
like
these kinds of things that was my
attempt at low frequency versus high
frequency auditory stimuli or at the
spatial frequency or what in the
auditory domain would be called the
temporal frequency is it
or is it
all we've changed there is the temporal
frequency the sound was somewhat the
same but the distance between those
sounds was different
you get the idea
so they have access to these people in
these different conditions and they can
put them in the brain scanner and they
can do that before and after having
taken psilocybin and the long and short
of this study is that
psilocybin changes one's experience of
music not just during the psilocybin
Journey itself but thereafter and in
fact it changes one's emotional response
to music
in very interesting ways for instance
one of the more common features of major
depression is that people don't derive
as much pleasure from different types of
experiences whether or not it's food or
sex or social experiences to the point
where sometimes they just stop trying to
seek out those experiences
people with depression often feel as if
music no longer has the same impact it
just doesn't really lift them up very
much this study found that people who
have taken psilocybin
according to the parameters we talked
about earlier can get a return of the
elevated emotionality the positive
emotions associated with music that
formerly made them feel good in other
words they can feel music again they can
feel good in response to music again now
this is interesting because in theory
could be that psilocybin simply allowed
them to access the emotions around music
again more generally but that's actually
not what this paper and some other
papers that have been published
report rather
it seems that taking psilocybin
can increase one's positive perception
of music that one likes
and can tone down or reduce the
depressiveness or the sadness of music
that tends to make one sad
even after the psilocybin has worn off
and for a long period of time afterwards
maybe even forever although no study of
course can be carried out forever
because forever is forever what we do
know however is that psilocybin can
rewire the connections between the
emotion centers in the brain
and the networks that control auditory
perception of music
and leads to this condition in which
people who felt like I was depressed or
I couldn't feel the music I just wasn't
getting the same lift and Joy from it
again they can start to experience more
joy from that music again and that music
that made them feel sad and depressed
has a diminished capacity to make them
feel sad and depressed and there's a lot
of neuroimaging data in this paper that
point to the specific brain areas that
include areas like the ventral tegmental
area that can explain why these sorts of
effects would occur so this isn't just
subjective reports of people saying oh
yeah you know I was depressed and music
didn't feel really good and now it feels
great or that used to make me feel so
sad and now I feel like I have a
capacity to listen to that without being
you know crushed by feelings of sadness
the paper included some subjective
reports of that sort but then was able
to link those to changes in brain
circuitry and brain activation in
response to music using neuroimaging so
in that way it really points to both the
subjective and structural and functional
changes that psilocybin can bring about
through that expand did connectivity
between brain errors because remember
during the psilocybin session
it's not as if music or the perception
of music is specifically being looked at
or focused on in these studies rather
music is playing people are in the eye
mask they're feeling all sorts of things
they're breathing they're hearing their
touch it's all happening all at once
there's a peak it's long there's a long
taper the music's changing okay all of
that took place in this study as well
but it is after the session When
comparing brain activation states to
music of a particular type sad or happy
and comparing that to the patterns of
brain activation that occurred before
the psilocybin Journey
that they discover that people's brains
have rewired during the psilocybin
session in a way that allows them to
experience joy in response to music
again so that's one of the more rigorous
studies I was able to find that
addresses this question of whether or
not psilocybin really does rewire the
brain in ways that allows us to be more
creative and experience life differently
after the psilocybin session now that
paper didn't Focus specifically on
creativity I did an entire episode on
creativity that talked about different
types of meditation like open monitoring
meditation it talked about different
patterns of thinking that one can
actually practice to increase creativity
we had arguably one of the most creative
people on the planet Rick Rubin
came on this podcast talked about the
creative process from the perspective of
music and his role in producing music so
you can check out those episodes if
you're interested in the neural
circuitry related to creativity at least
at the time of recording this episode
there haven't been a lot of studies
looking specifically at the brain
networks that we think are involved in
creativity and how those change in
response to psilocybin and other
psychedelics I imagine those studies are
either happening now or will happen in
the future but the studies I just
described referring to the changes in
emotionality and responses to music I
think provide a nice template for what's
likely happening
both during psilocybin Journeys and
after those psilocybin Journeys when we
talk about less hierarchical
organization more connectivity between
brain areas
what it's pointing to is the fact that
during the psilocybin Journey people
have the opportunity to learn new
relationships between different sensory
and emotional states
and those new relationships
seem to persist long after the
Psychedelic Journey has been finished
and a lot of people researching
psilocybin in the clinical setting think
that that's one of the major reasons why
psilocybin and other psychedelics can
rewire our relationship to things more
broadly it allows for new learning new
contingencies and when we look at
depression we often think you know
diminished mood people now have an
appetite they're not interested in
Social relationships or romantic
relationships they're really struggling
and all of that of course is true but
another lens to look at depression
through is that a lot of that thinking
and a lot of those emotional states that
are negative are somewhat habitual they
relate to a sort of implicit
understanding and living out of the idea
that a leads to B leads to C okay you
seek out a relationship it doesn't work
out try a new job you don't get the job
you get the job it's no good all these
negative outcomes of if a then B then C
and it does seem that psilocybin can
have this effect of invoking new
patterns of learning new considerations
about what might be possible and indeed
may even lead to actual rewiring of the
emotion centers in the brain with these
other brain areas and vice versa in ways
that eject people from the psilocybin
session thinking oh you know yeah I used
to feel this way about something work
relationships myself Etc but I'm willing
to consider this other possibility or
this other possibility seems at least
partially true to the extent that I'm
willing to go out and evaluate that now
here I'm speaking very subjectively but
remember we have to tie back the
subjective experiences and changes of
things like music and motion and our
relationship to life and jobs and
relationships back to the cell biology
and chemistry of psilocybin because
ultimately it really is just a chemical
activating receptors those receptors
changing networks in the brain and the
journey itself seems to be the time when
all of those changes are put in motion
it's like a boulder that gets rolling in
fact I think the best way to think about
psilocybin and other psychedelics is
that they initiate the neuroplasticity
process but they are not the
neuroplasticity process itself and the
journey itself is not where all the
neuroplasticity occurs we know that for
sure in fact if you want to imagine how
psilocybin and other psychedelics work
to change the brain think about them as
a wedge that gets underneath the boulder
that is the neuroplasticity that gets
rolling forward and then think about
whether or not the plasticity is
adaptive or maladaptive whether or not
it actually serves you in your life on a
daily basis or not depending on whether
or not you're using your conscious brain
to move that Boulder in a particular
direction right not just bulldozing
through things and destroying them but
clearing a path through old ineffective
maybe even destructive patterns of
thoughts or emotions Etc I give you that
analogy because I think it more
accurately captures what psychedelics
like psilocybin are doing rather than
the typical discussion around
psychedelics that we tend to hear which
is that oh it creates plasticity and
plasticity is what you want for the next
couple of minutes I'd like to focus on
some of the key and stereotype that is
characteristic experiences that people
tend to have during a psilocybin Journey
because there's some really interesting
research on this these are phrases that
perhaps you've heard before things like
letting go ego dissolution feelings of
connectedness well all of that is very
subjective on the one hand those words
are heard often enough and repeatedly
enough
in psilocybin sessions and after
psilocybin sessions along with this
description of this psilocybin
experience as one of the most profound
of one's life where one of the most
positive in the ideal case of one's life
that they are worth exploring we should
also of course explore the so-called bad
trip the possibility that someone will
have a not good time or even very
frightening time while under the
influence of psilocybin so there have
been some scientific studies that have
explored what sorts of subjective
experiences that is thoughts and
feelings
insights that people have that relate to
positive therapeutic outcomes and more
generally with the sense that the
psilocybin Journey was positive or maybe
even tremendously positive in one's life
so while there's a century or more of
writings about psychedelics that
describe things like enhanced feelings
of connectedness or dissolution of the
ego the loss of one sense of self and
then the regaining of one sense of self
and so on there's a particular paper
that describes some of those things in
terms of rating scales that is the sorts
of tests that people can take in which
they answer particular questions and
that link back to things like feelings
of connectedness and ego dissolution
that allows us to put some numbers to
those experiences and to look at some of
the statistics associated with those
experiences and this is really what's
important about scientific studies
whether or not a measure is subjective
so someone's self-reporting how they
felt or feel or whether or not it's
measure of blood pressure or of a
chemical in the bloodstream Etc
it's the use of numbers and statistics
that allows comparison between different
groups and that can be compared between
studies that allows us to make some firm
conclusions about what sorts of things
psilocybin may or may not be doing when
it's effective or not so the paper I'd
like to highlight is entitled quality of
acute psychedelic experience predicts
therapeutic efficacy of psilocybin for
treatment resistant depression I'll put
a link to this paper in the show note
captions but the basic Contour of this
paper is that they looked at subjects
that underwent two different psilocybin
sessions one at a relatively low-ish
dose of 10 milligrams of psilocybin and
that would be equivalent to about one
gram of psychedelic mushrooms more or
less
and a second session involving subjects
taking 25 milligrams of psilocybin or
what's roughly equivalent to somebody
taking two and a half grams of
psilocybin mushrooms
those people then answered What's called
the Altered States Of Consciousness
questionnaire which allowed them to
address and here I'm paraphrasing the
quality of experiences in the 25
milligram psilocybin session so without
going into too much detail it's often
the case in these sorts of two session
studies that subjects will take a
slightly lower dose of psilocybin to
familiarize themselves with the
experience and then the higher dose that
leads to the more intense experience
intense meaning a bigger more intense
Peak a longer session overall greater
distortions in emotionality and
perceptual experience all the stuff we
talked about before
so what this study found is that one of
the key features if not the key feature
of
a positive quote unquote
psychedelic experience is this sense of
oceanic boundlessness occurring at some
point during the Psychedelic Journey now
Oceanic boundlessness doesn't
necessarily mean anything to any of us
it probably means different things to
different people
it's this idea that one is experiencing
something extremely unusual even
mystical kind of Beyond this world and
one's normal experience
but that it's not aligned with any
specific outcome in the moment it's not
directly attached to anyone feeling or
memory or thought process it's this it's
a little bit tough to describe because I
can guarantee you I'm not on psilocybin
or any psychedelics right now
and I can only imagine that you're not
although some of you might be I can't
even imagine what this uh podcast would
um be like for somebody on psilocybin at
this moment but in any case Oceanic
boundlessness a feeling of
The Experience being mystical and not
really heading in any one particular
direction just a feeling of massive
connectedness with one's environment
both in the room and session perhaps
with the guides with oneself with one's
past with one's present people outside
the room with the entire world maybe
even the universe that sort of thing
the intensity of that experience of
oceanic boundlessness the mystical
experience
seems to be positively correlated with
positive therapeutic outcomes that is
relief from major depression
now during the Psychedelic Journey as we
talked about before there are a number
of steps that one typically goes through
so there's the build up to First
experiencing the effects of the drug
about maybe 20 to 45 minutes into the
journey or trip then the peak and it is
during that Peak that people often feel
the sense of oceanic boundlessness
however
it's also often the case that it is
during the peak where the maximum
intensity of emotion and we know based
on Direct measurements also increases in
blood pressure and heart rate often very
significant increases in anxiety and
fear as well that people will experience
things like ego dissolution and the
guides role at that point is of course
to keep the person safe make sure they
don't run out of the room jump out of a
window run into traffic sadly these are
things that have happened outside of a
strong healthy safe set and setting but
the guide's role is to keep the person
safe but also to encourage them to let
go and move through that experience to
experience the anxiety allow it to Peak
allow them to see that they're not going
to die from that anxiety they're not
going to dissolve they won't lose their
sense of self completely or they may
temporarily feel as if they lose their
sense of self but then they feel it
restored
at various intervals during the peak or
as they exit that Peak and move toward
the say second third fourth fifth hour
of the session
so when exactly these feelings of
oceanic boundlessness and ego
dissolution occur varies from person to
person but typically it's during the
peak that the ego dissolution the fear
and the need to quote unquote let go
is most typical I think perhaps the best
way to describe the data in this paper
in a way that's meaningful to everybody
is to refer you to figure two which if
you're not looking at the paper won't
mean anything to you but I'll describe
it and if you do want to take a look at
figure two again you can access the
paper in the show note captions what
they did is they looked at a number of
different subjective measures things
like experience of unity the feeling
that one is connected to others into the
world things like spirituality whether
or not the whole thing felt like a
spiritual experience whether or not it
was a blissful State whether or not
there were insights whether or not
somebody felt disembodied out of body
whether or not somebody had a lot of
anxiety whether or not they had these
synesthesias these blending of visual
auditory touch and breathing and things
of that sort and they addressed which of
those measures related to the positive
clinical outcomes that were observed
later after the psilocybin wore off and
while I'm not going to go Point by Point
through each one of these measures
there's a general feature to emerge from
the study which is that
the experience of unity
sense that the psilocybin Journey was
spiritual
an experience of bliss at some point
inside of the psilocybin Journey
the sense that there were insights that
there were learnings about one's life
and oneself
when those things were experienced very
strongly that correlated with the person
being what was called a responder to the
psilocybin treatment meaning they got
relief from their depression whereas
people who felt less of that okay so the
non-responders as they're called
the people who do not benefit so much in
the long run from the psilocybin
treatment tended to report less of an
experience of unity less of a spiritual
experience less of a blissful State less
insightfulness
and so on
whereas there were very few differences
between the people that derived benefit
from the psilocybin treatment and those
did not along the dimensions of
synesthesia this blending of different
perceptions that ordinarily doesn't
occur for most people or
complex imagery right put simply
everyone who took psilocybin in this
study at 25 milligrams saw a complex
imagery they saw a lot of hallucinations
but just seeing hallucinations did not
lead to the positive clinical outcomes
in terms of mood
anxiety was a very interesting measure
here because ordinarily we think of the
ego dissolution the letting go is such a
key component of the Psychedelic journey
in terms of the positive therapeutic
outcomes this has been discussed quite a
lot and in full disclosure Robin Carter
Harris has already come on to record an
episode of the Hebrew and Loud podcast
that episode hasn't been released yet
but it will be released soon and he
talks about the importance of this
letting go in terms of the positive
clinical outcomes of the psilocybin
journey and indeed that is true and I
should also mention that Dr Matthew
Johnson from Johns Hopkins who also runs
a laboratory exploring psychedelics and
their role in treating things like
eating disorders and depression Etc also
doing incredible work also talked about
the importance of letting go during the
psilocybinary this ego dissolution this
ability to move through the anxiety and
again I can't underscore this enough
because it's been told to me over and
over again by the top researchers in
this area that people head into that
peaking phase of the psilocybin journey
and oftentimes it is not pleasant for
them their feeling like it's
uncomfortable it's scary and their heart
rate is up and their blood pressure is
up and they're having a hard time
calming down then they want to calm down
but it does seem that while the guides
should not ramp them up and get them
more stressed that the ability to move
through that stressful period to
somewhat guide oneself or to be
encouraged to guide oneself through that
Peak and that anxiety and the fear of
losing oneself and the so-called ego
dissolution that occurs is an important
feature for an effective therapeutic
session
in this study
anxiety itself was inversely correlated
with a positive therapeutic outcome okay
so this is important and somewhat
nuanced on the one hand I'm telling you
that the Letting Go the ego dissolution
does seem to be important in terms of
reporting a psychedelic experience as
effective as having accomplished
something and perhaps even explaining
some of the long-term positive effects
to emerge from that psychedelic journey
in this case psilocybin cherny however
non-responders that is people who did
psilocybin but did not have a positive
therapeutic outcome in comparison to the
responders
those non-responders tended to have
higher subjective ratings of anxiety
than did the responders so this is
important and what it speaks to is the
fact that well yes letting go during the
session experiencing some anxiety
perhaps even ego dissolution and the of
dissolving of self and then the return
of self is important
it is also important it seems that
anxiety not be so so high or
subjectively experienced as so high that
one does not experience the positive
neuronal rewiring that leads to a more
pervasive elevated mood okay so I'm
definitely saying two things at once
because I'm trying to capture the data
accurately it would not be fair for me
to say just let go experience as much
anxiety as is possible and that's part
of the process
yes Letting Go Again an air quote seems
to be important for one's experience of
the Psychedelic journey in particular
around the peak that occurs about two
hours in or so
however extreme levels of anxiety
seem inversely correlated or negatively
correlated would be the better way to
put it with the Positive therapeutic
outcome or really from depression
so this takes us back to all of the
things we've been talking about thus far
not just the chemistry and biological
action of psilocybin but the key
importance of getting dosage right the
key importance of making sure that
you're in a safe environment but also
one in which the guides really know what
they're doing I think this is one of the
biggest and most important reasons for
having well-trained guides who really
understand the Contour of the
Psychedelic Journey but are also trained
in how to help somebody with their
anxiety in real time while they're under
the effects of psilocybin and of course
to help people integrate those feelings
of high anxiety and maybe guide them
back down to a calmer State during the
Psychedelic session itself
here I can just mention some unpublished
data in studies and again these are very
preliminary but through discussions with
Dr Matthew Johnson who's running these
psilocybin and other sorts of
psychedelic trials at Johns Hopkins
he and I discuss the importance of
having a real-time tool to adjust
anxiety while under the influence of
psychedelics like psilocybin and there
he
asked and they've started to incorporate
is my understanding some of the
real-time respiration tools that is
breathing tools that we know based on
work in my laboratory Dr David Spiegel's
laboratory can reduce anxiety very
quickly in real time and that involves
the use of the so-called physiological
Psy I've talked a lot about this before
on previous podcasts so rather than
explain it to you again here now we'll
put a link to the physiological side I
do a demonstration of it in the show
note captions I'll also link to a recent
paper that we published in cell reports
medicine this was a collaborative work
that my laboratory did with Dr David
Spiegel's Laboratory
at Stanford School of Medicine showing
that the physiological size among the
different deliberate respiration
techniques one of the fastest and most
effective ways to reduce levels of
autonomic arousal AKA anxiety or stress
and Dr Matthew Johnson's laboratory
started to incorporate physiological
size Within These psychedelic sessions
as a tool that the guides can refer
people to
before the session begins teaching it to
them so they realize they can calm
themselves down if necessary in real
time it works the first time it works
every time this is not because it's some
magic breathing technique that I created
it certainly is not this is a naturally
occurring pattern of breathing that
occurs in sleeping and waking but that
when done deliberately leads to very
rapid and quite significant decreases in
Stress and Anxiety and then when people
are inside of the Psychedelic session if
they feel their anxiety levels are going
too high they're heading toward what
might be called a quote unquote bad trip
they're starting to panic or really
think they're going to have a panic
attack or die again the subjective
experience is going to be layered on top
of the physiological experience of one's
heart rate being really elevated saw a
stress and agitation by using the
physiological site inside of the
Psychedelic session Dr Johnson's
laboratory and I believe at least one
other laboratory are starting to use
breathing techniques such as the
physiological side as a way for these
people who are under the influence of
psilocybin to self-direct their own calm
and to bring that level of anxiety down
so that they can continue to move
through the peak and move through the
other phases of the Psychedelic journey
in ways that could be most beneficial
for them so to close out the description
of this really wonderful study
and by the way it's another one from the
cardhart Harris laboratory about
the subjective experience of ego
dissolution or Oceanic boundlessness
this mystical State as so key
as a component of a positive psilocybin
Journey I'll just read for you the final
sentence of this paper because it
captures it so well
quote it seems vital that appropriate
consideration is paid to the importance
of promoting a certain kind of
experience as the quality of that
experience may be the critical
determinant of therapeutic success now
before we move into what will be a very
brief description of some of the other
rewiring phenomena that psilocybin can
induce
and then into some of the therapeutic
applications of psilocybin as they
relate to these recent really exciting
clinical trials for depression and
addictive disorders and things of that
sort
I just want to cue everybody to a paper
that I think many people will want to
take a look at in thinking about
psilocybin
and I'll provide a link to this paper as
well in the show note captions this
paper is entitled therapeutic use of
psilocybin practical considerations for
dosing and administration and this is a
wonderful paper because it really goes
step by step through the pharmacology of
psilocybin of which you now understand a
bit but it goes in to a bit more detail
but then it also really nicely describes
the Contour of a psilocybin session and
what's happening at the level of
chemistry
early middle Peak and toward the end of
the psilocybin session and then also
importantly it gets into issues of
dosage and translating from mushrooms to
psilocybin itself to silacin things I
talked about earlier but in a bit more
detail if you'd like to see that detail
and then perhaps most importantly
there's a section on contraindications
where it points out that of course women
who are pregnant
or breastfeeding people who have a
predisposition to psychosis
those people should really avoid the use
of psilocybin and other psychedelics
entirely it also talks about where the
evidence is strong moderate and weak
for the use of psilocybin for treatment
of various disorders and I can just
summarize that very quickly because it's
where we're going ahead in a few minutes
which is that the most evidence for
positive therapeutic outcomes in
response to psilocybin taken and
conducted in the manner that we've been
describing today in terms of dosage and
journey set and setting is for
cancer-related depression
cancer related anxiety and treatment
resistant depression that's where most
of the evidence resides there's also
some evidence for the use of psilocybin
Journeys and again this is typically one
or two psilocybin Journeys spaced in the
cases of two Journeys anywhere from one
to two weeks apart and again with all of
the same Contour of supports and set and
setting that we've been talking about
today
and there there's some evidence
for improvement in terms of outcomes in
alcohol use disorder Independence and
tobacco addiction and then finally
there's the least amount of evidence
although there is clinical trial support
for relief or partial relief
for obsessive-compulsive disorder
cluster headaches and migraines and
demoralization due to AIDS diagnosis
okay so this paper has a lot of really
interesting information in terms of
different conditions in terms of dosage
and again contraindications and what's
called Adverse Events what sorts of bad
things can and do happen as a
consequence of psilocybin and other
types of psychedelic Journeys both
during and after those psilocybin or
psychedelic sessions we'll talk a bit
more about this when we go into some of
those clinical studies because adverse
reactions is always a key measure in any
clinical study so very soon we'll get
into the more recent clinical studies
related to
psilocybin for the use of treating
depression and some other conditions but
before we do that I'd be remiss if I
didn't talk about how psilocybin does
and does not change the brain what is
and what is not known about that in fact
when I put out the call for questions
about psilocybin
many of the questions related to these
issues
the first thing to understand is that a
psilocybin Journey
is really a way to try and put that
wedge under the boulder as I described
it to try and invoke neuroplasticity of
a particular kind and in that way it's
kind of remarkable if you think about it
that everyone has different lives
different experiences psychedelics in
this case psilocybin are activating
these brain networks that each of us has
more broadly than they would normally be
activated these are very abnormal
patterns of thinking and perceiving and
experiencing our emotional and physical
life Etc
and yet so often the outcomes are
positive not always but the outcomes are
positive the experience is positive even
though it might have these anxiety
moments or components within them it's
very important to understand that
psilocybin and the journey while
important
are not really what all of this is about
it's really about neuroplasticity so
researchers in particular
neuroscientists are very intensely
interested in understanding what sorts
of neuroplasticity psilocybin creates
because it turns out there are lots of
different types or processes involved
with neuroplasticity for instance
brain networks Behavior thinking emotion
Etc can change because of the addition
of new neurons that's one form of
neuroplasticity that's referred to as
neurogenesis the production of new
neurons most typically in the so-called
dentate gyrus or other sub-regions of
the hippocampus a brain area involved in
learning and memory
neurogenesis in other regions of the
adult human brain are exceedingly rare
and to be honest may not occur at all
this is a debated area
or we could do an entire episode about
this but for the most part
neuroscientists don't really believe
that your neocortex your striatum your
cerebellum
has that much neurogenesis that's
related to learning and memory of new
things or new experiences
and we don't actually think that occurs
as a consequence of taking psilocybin
either
now some of you who are familiar with
for instance the cerebellum might be
saying wait what about granular cell
proliferation in the cerebellum or what
about the rostral migratory stream from
The soverentricular Zone where there are
neuroblasts you know spitting out little
new neurons that migrate into the nose
to replenish the olfactory in our own
population yes that's all true that does
occur it's been observed in mice it's
been observed in monkeys and to some
extent it's been observed in humans but
it's not again I repeat it is not a
prominent feature of learning
an acquisition of new skills new ideas
or new emotional states
perhaps the best supported evidence for
neurogenesis underlying new thoughts
experiences abilities emotions Etc is
the production of new neurons in that
dentate gyrus sub-region of the
hippocampus and that probably does occur
in humans but neurogenesis is not really
the dominant mode of changing neural
circuitry in adult humans it might be
a player in adolescence in young
childhood it is certainly a player
before we are born when we are still in
utero but then the brain is being wired
up in many different ways including the
addition of new neurons and changing of
connections
all this is to say that while
neurogenesis is a really sticky idea and
it makes great headlines the addition of
new neurons is not really the way that
the brain changes under psilocybin
other psychedelics or just generally
it's perhaps responsible for maybe one
to two percent and I'm being generous
there of the rewiring events that are
going to be most important for all of us
so we need to set that down and cement
that there until further Evidence comes
out to the contrary that's certainly
where I and here I feel comfortable
speaking for the majority of
neuroscientists out there professional
neuroscientists that is
the paper showing adult neurogenesis are
interesting but they don't really
explain most of the plasticity that
occurs in the adult human brain so if
neurogenesis ain't it what is well it's
very clear that psilocybin other
psychedelics
and any sort of Behavioral or drug
intervention that can induce
neuroplasticity does so largely through
the addition or strengthening of new
neural connections or through the
elimination or weakening of other neural
connections
and if you look at the data exploring
the mechanistic basis for
psilocybin-induced neuroplasticity
it's mostly focused on animal brains
animal models mice and rats in
particular a little bit on primates but
mostly mice and rats because that's
where the interventions can be done of
knockout animals of you know Imaging the
brain in real time of course there are
the beautiful studies of Robin cardard
Harris and others exploring
neuroplasticity at the level of brain
Imaging at the level of ultrasound
measurements of how active are certain
brain areas in humans how extensive was
you know the modularity or not extensive
is the modulator et cetera the stuff we
talked about earlier so in other words
there are neuroplasticity studies the
effects of psilocybin in humans but in
terms of underlying mechanisms of
neuroplasticity I think the predominant
theory is that
psilocybin induces neuroplasticity
through the addition of Novel
Connections in those pyramidal neurons
of the frontal cortex elsewhere in the
cortex and certainly also in the visual
cortex probably also subcortically as
well below the cerebral cortex in areas
like the thalamus maybe even in the
brain stem as well
and that those neuroplasticity events
are structural and functional and they
involve a couple of basic events the
most prominent of which is the growth of
dendrites dendrites are those little
branches or processes that come out of
the the neurons not just the pyramidal
neurons but other neurons as well but
since we're talking mainly about
pyramidal neurons today both the apical
those ones that top they're called the
apical Tufts they're the ones that reach
laterally to connect with other neurons
communicate with other neurons so we
talked about before as well as the
dendrites that come out of the base of
those pyramidal neurons those processes
grow in response to psilocybin
as well as the addition of what are
called dendritic spine so the dendrites
are the branches the spines are these
little protrusions that grow out they
actually in here I don't know if this is
coincidence or not again I always say I
wasn't consulted the design phase but
these little protrusions actually look
like little mushrooms they have a little
stalk and they have a little head a
little uh spine head and those little
spines so think of these as like little
tiny mushroom appearing okay they aren't
actual mushrooms okay the first person
that puts in the comments oh my goodness
I learned today that mushrooms grow out
of our neurons when we take magic
mushrooms that is not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that these little
mushroom-shaped protrusions that we're
calling dendritic spines do in fact grow
out of dendritic branches of neurons
when animals ingest psilocybin or are
injected with psilocybin and that those
little mushroom-shaped protrusions are
the sites of new excitatory connections
new locations for input from other
neurons to activate those neurons that
have those little mushroom shaped
protrusions if you'd like to see
examples of this both movies and still
shots it's pretty remarkable there's a
paper that I'll provide a link to in the
show note captions this was published in
the journal neuron cell Press Journal
excellent Journal entitled psilocybin
induces rapid and persistent growth of
dendritic spines in the frontal cortex
in Vivo so these measurements were done
in the mouse equivalent more or less of
the prefrontal cortex there's some
interesting details in this paper for
instance that those new connections
persist so they don't just grow out
during the psilocybin being active in
the bloodstream and brain of the animal
they persist okay so this may again may
explain some of the persistent changes
that occur in people after psilocybin
Journeys they may too grow new spines I
should also mention that a reduction in
the number of dendritic spines these
little mushroom-shaped protrusions in
the frontal cortex neurons of humans
occurs in depressed patients we know
that from postmortem tissue and that
drugs that relieve depression or that
treatments including behavioral
treatments that provide some relief from
depression do seem to be correlated with
increases in spine growth in frontal
cortex neurons as well so this raises a
very interesting idea which is
perhaps it's the growth of new
connections these new dendritic spines
in particular neurons that's created by
administration of psilocybin that
explains the relief from depression that
people experience so this is just one
paper but it's one paper of a growing
body of work showing that yes indeed
psilocybin induces both structural and
functional plasticity in the human and
animal brain
it does that in the human brain at
therapeutic doses of anywhere from 10 to
25 perhaps even 30 milligrams per
session one or two sessions I should
mention that the mouse studies tended to
use quite high doses of psilocybin I was
actually I wasn't shocked but I was
somewhat wide-eyed for a moment to
realize that most of the studies looking
at changes in plasticity
in the mouse brain in response to
psilocybin use the equivalent of one
milligram per kilogram of body weight
which is if you do the math and you
translate what we were talking about
before in terms of dosages I'll just
spare you all the time
it's about double the sorts of dosages
that are typically used in humans maybe
even triple in some cases now it's often
the case in animal studies because of
the metabolism of animals being
different but also because
you know seeing effects of drugs in
animal studies
can be difficult they did use a dose
response anywhere from zero to 0.25 to
half to one to two milligrams per
kilogram of psilocybin in the study so
they had a dose response curve but
focused mainly on this one milligram per
kilogram dosage in any event the point
is that many of the studies that
describe these pretty dramatic
structural changes in the animal brain
most typically the mouse sprain in
response to psilocybin used dosages of
psilocybin that if translated to humans
would be about double the human
therapeutic dose so that is something
that we need to take into consideration
nonetheless it's very clear that in both
animal studies and humans psilocybin is
inducing both structural and functional
changes in brain circuitry and that in
humans
the network connectivity is being
changed dramatically we talked about
those data earlier and that the
underlying basis for that might be again
might be we don't know for sure
the addition of new dendritic spines on
these pyramidal neurons that we've been
talking about repeatedly throughout
today's episode although neurogenesis
perhaps and other modes of
neuroplasticity such as the elimination
of certain connections perhaps related
to
unhealthy maladaptive thoughts or or
feeling that a particular sad song is
overwhelmingly sad it could be the case
that those sorts of things change
subjectively because of the removal of
neural connections if you're going to
think like a neurobiologist or scientist
for that matter you don't ever want to
think that one mechanism can explain all
the effects of a given drug or a given
experience is almost certainly likely to
be the consequence of multiple
mechanisms acting in parallel and
because I know there are people out
there who would like to know even more
about the neuroplasticity induced by
psychedelics including psilocybin
there's a wonderful review that I
provide a link to in the show note
captions entitled psychedelics and
neuroplasticity a systematic review
unraveling the biological underpinnings
of psychedelics
this review is great because it goes a
Step Beyond just psilocybin silosin
binding to the serotonin 2A receptor and
things like brain derived nootrophic
Factor it actually talks a lot about the
intracellular signaling and exactly how
neurons change their excitability
patterns based on this activation of the
serotonin to a receptor it's probably
more detail than most of you out there
are interested in but if you are
interested in that level of detail this
is a wonderful Open Access review so a
few minutes ago I talked about where
there is strong modest and somewhat weak
or rather I should say minimal evidence
for the therapeutic use of psilocybin to
treat various disorders and across the
board it really appears that major
depression and
so-called intractable depression in some
cases is where we're seeing the most
exciting research to date now keep in
mind that because of the controlled
substance act being invoked in 1970 in
the United States and because it was
only just a few years ago really only
about five years ago that psychedelics
including psilocybin received what's
called breakthrough status at the FDA
that there are now a lot of clinical
trials exploring how psilocybin can
impact various things like mood
disorders addictive disorders and so on
prior to 2018 when that therapeutic
breakthrough potential was established
in the United States
I think a lot of people in the so-called
psychedelics Community had the sense and
the Really the belief that these drugs
had enormous potential
but they just weren't being explored
that extensively so I do want to give a
nod to the incredible researchers such
as Robin carder Harris but also Matthew
Johnson Roland Griffis Nolan Williams
and many others okay I'm certainly not
listing off everybody that would take
hours but
those researchers have really pioneered
both the legal efforts and the funding
efforts and most importantly the
research efforts defining the clinical
data that I'm about to describe and here
I'm going to summarize the clinical data
in a bit of a top Contour fashion just
giving you the kind of highlights
we will of course provide links to the
papers if you'd like to look into it
further but I'm only giving you the top
Contour because I've had the great
Fortune of having Matthew Johnson on
this podcast before you can find that
episode at hubermanlab.com
just simply put Matt's name or
psychedelics into the search function
it'll take you to that episode in all
formats or links to all formats rather
I've also had the great Fortune of
sitting down recently with Dr Robert and
cardart Harris to talk about his work at
University of California San Francisco
on psilocybin LSD
Ayahuasca and DMT as it relates to
depression and other disorders and that
episode which also will be released at
hubermanlab.com and on all platforms
YouTube Apple Spotify really goes in
depth into these clinical studies and
what those studies really look like you
know who's in the room whether or not
people just get one dose or two doses
how far apart those are separated all of
that is covered in extensive detail in
that what I found to be wonderful
discussion with Dr Robin Carhart Harris
so if you're interested in all of the
details as it relates to clinical
application of psychedelics stay tuned
for that episode soon again you can find
that at hubermanlab.com and on all
Platforms in the meantime I would be
remiss if I didn't include a bit of
discussion about what has been observed
in terms of using psilocybin Journeys as
a way to treat depression because the
data are just oh so exciting
again these data really started to
surface as the consequence of studies
that were initiated around
2006 in just a few select Laboratories
and then really picked up in terms of
the number of Laboratories and number of
studies
between 2018 and now so what you'll
notice is that most of the papers I'm
about to describe were published in for
instance phenomenal journals New England
Journal of Medicine in 2021 New England
Journal medicine
November 2022
um Journal of the American Medical
Association Psychiatry just very
recently 2021 so these are very recent
papers
essentially all of these clinical
studies involve either one or two
psilocybin sessions
the dosages that were explored range
from zero milligrams of placebo if you
will
10 milligrams some cases 25 milligrams
in some cases 30 milligrams
and most typically people receive the
same dosage for both sessions if indeed
they did both sessions however there's
at least one study looking at just one
single episode of psilocybin
Administration so this is the paper
entitled no surprise single dose
psilocybin for treatment resistant
episode of major depression this is
published in the New England Journal
medicine in November of 2022.
I'll just summarize the results of this
single Application Study they randomly
assign subjects who had
treatment-resistant depression so they'd
resisted treatment to other things to
receive a single dose of a synthetic
formulation of psilocybin so they're not
eating mushrooms they're getting a
synthetic dose of psilocybin but the
dose is known
of either 25 milligrams 10 milligrams or
one milligram which was the control
and they receive psychological support
there were a number of different tests
subjective tests of depression
taken before and after the psilocybin
Journey they had about
75 to 79 participants in each group
again at the three different doses 25 10
or one milligram
and they looked at the changes in these
scores these depression related scores
on these tests there are many results
from this paper one could summarize but
among the most important results I can
summarize from the discussion and here
I'm paraphrasing that the change in
Baseline levels of depression that is
at week three
following the psilocybin session was
significantly better that is people
experienced more relief or more people
experienced more relief from the 25
milligram dose than from the one
milligram dose
and this is important there was no
significant difference between the 10
milligram dose and the one milligram
dose
this really points to the fact that the
25 to 30 milligram dose that's used in
the largest numbers of studies exploring
treatment resistant depression really
seems to be I don't want to say the best
dose but the most effective dose at
least in this clinical context in this
set in setting and with this particular
patient population so we want to be
careful to say that so that one doesn't
just translate that 25 milligrams is
better than 10 milligrams although in
this study it was for sake of treatment
resistant depression relief
there were a number of other key aspects
of this paper
in particular the exploration of
so-called Adverse Events so things like
headaches propensity for self-harm
actual self-harm anxiety and so on
it's worth mentioning that there were
Adverse Events in essentially every
group
the number of Adverse Events was highest
in the 25 milligram dose group this is
observed in other studies as well with
higher dosages
there tends to be greater relief from
depressive symptoms but also a greater
chance for Adverse Events some of those
Adverse Events can be quite severe so
feelings of suicidal ideation Etc some
of them one could consider a little less
severe mild headache or severe headache
that was transient or anxiety that was
transient again highly individual
responses
we could go line by line and table by
table through this paper which we won't
because there's a lot of data again
we'll provide a link to this paper if
you'd like to peruse it yourself it's
fairly straightforward to read that's
one thing that's nice about these um
clinical trials is they tend to be
written in Fairly non-technical language
although there's a little bit of
technical language
the important point is that a single
dose of 25 milligrams of psilocybin
provided significant relief from
treatment-resistant depression in this
particular patient population but it is
not the case that 100 of the people who
took 25 milligrams of psilocybin
experience that relief however the
majority of them did now when you say
majority in science you really need to
look to numbers and the reason I'm not
telling you oh it was 75 or 60 percent
or 50 percent is because it depends on
which time Point people were analyzed
people were asked about their level of
depression relief immediately after one
week after two weeks after three weeks
after
and the degree of relief tended to
change over time in fact it tended to
diminish over time but it was also
stable or remarkably stable I should say
at least by my read
in the 25 milligram dose group and that
is summarized nicely in figure two of
the paper because they explored these
people's levels of depression out to
week 12 and they still saw
a significant degree of depression
relief 12 weeks after the single 25
milligram psilocybin dose session so as
I mentioned earlier there are now about
a dozen or so excellent studies clinical
trials exploring the use of single or
two session psilocybin treatment in that
25 to 30 milligram range which seems to
be the most effective dose for
long-lasting relief from depression
each one of those studies explored
something different as is important
replication is also important of course
in order to validate previous studies
but for instance there have been
comparisons of psilocybin versus ssris
or other antidepressants there have been
comparisons of psilocybin Plus
psychoanalysis or cognitive behavioral
therapy versus cognitive behavioral
therapy alone or psychoanalysis alone
and so there's a lot of evaluation now
of the clinical outcomes and the
statistical outcomes of these subjective
measures and even some objective
measures of neurochemistry where that's
possible in terms of trying to
understand
if and how psilocybin is effective for
the treatment of depression and the
major takeaway is that indeed it does
seem to be the case and the numbers that
I feel comfortable not throwing out
there but putting out to you reflect my
conversation with Robin cardhart Harris
again that will be released soon at
hubermanlab.com as well as takeaways
from
what I would say are the six
broadest studies meaning they have the
widest range of age groups the broadest
demographic in terms of the subjects
their backgrounds their levels of
Education men women ethnicity Etc
and a lot of that can be summarized in
the paper entitled effects of psilocybin
assisted therapy on major depressive
disorder this was a particular
randomized clinical trial
but in the discussion I think they
summarize it quite well which is that
if you look at the number of people who
take this 25 milligram dose twice
in session spaced about a week apart
what you will find is that anywhere from
60 to 75 percent of the people who have
major depressive disorder who do these
psilocybin sessions in the proper
setting report a good experience with it
have minimal Adverse Events coming out
of those sessions and in the weeks
following
those people experience substantial
positive relief from major depression in
ways that other treatments that they'd
explored including
antidepressant drugs cognitive
behavioral therapy and other types of
therapy alone could not provide now it's
a general feature of these clinical
trials focusing on psilocybin that
people are asked to stop taking their
antidepressants prior to participating
in the trial
it's also a general feature of these
trials that people are encouraged to not
suddenly start their antidepressant
treatment immediately afterwards because
of course that could confound the
results of the psilocybin treatment
however and this is a very important
thing to note all subjects were
encouraged not to avoid taking those
antidepressant medications if in fact
their clinician felt that it was
important for their immediate and
long-term survival so you know no one
should be reckless in thinking about
what to add or delete from their drug
protocol when dealing with depression
all right the outcomes could be very
severe in that case
nonetheless
we can paraphrase from the discussion of
the paper I just mentioned
because it really highlights the
incredible results that psilocybin
applied in these particular therapeutic
settings are providing and here again
I'm paraphrasing the present trial
showed that psilocybin administered in
the context of supportive psychotherapy
consisting of approximately 11 hours of
psychotherapy so this is going to be two
sessions of the psilocybin with proper
therapeutic support produced large rapid
and sustained antidepressant effects the
effect sizes reported in the study were
approximately 2.5 times greater than the
effects sizes found in psychotherapy
and more than four times greater than
the effect sizes found in
psychopharmacologic depression treatment
studies in other words four times the
positive effect observed with
typical ssris or other pharmacology of
that sort
these findings are consistent with the
literature that show that combined
pharmacotherapy and Psychotherapy were
more efficacious in the treatment of
major depressive disorder than either
intervention alone so again this points
to the fact that combining drug therapy
with talk therapy as it's often called
is going to be more effective than
either treatment alone here the drug
therapy psilocybin therapy and again
please don't take the fact that in these
studies they tended to ask people to not
take their antidepressant medication
heading into the study as a sign that
one should stop taking their
antidepressant medication rather I think
this study and other studies like it
again which will provide links to you in
the show note captions that are
discussed extensively in the episode
with Dr cardart Harris soon to come
really point to the incredible role that
psilocybin can have in creating an
experience inside of the session the
journey or the trip as it's called
as well as initiating neuroplastic
events perhaps the addition of dendritic
spines maybe even some new neurons maybe
although I don't think that's the
predominant mode
but that leads to these more extensive
connectivities in the brain the
so-called reduction in modular networks
enhanced
activity in brain areas that normally
wouldn't be talking to one another but
not doing that in any kind of haphazard
way it really does seem that the one or
two sessions of psilocybin that induce
these feelings of ego dissolution that
induce these feelings of oceanic
boundlessness right so mystical right
and in many ways it's what I find so
incredible about psilocybin and other
psychedelics is that despite the highly
mystical highly subjective and still at
this time somewhat top Contour
understanding of how they might exert
their effects you can highlight boldface
and underline might there right because
it hasn't really been firmly established
what the exact cell biological rewiring
events are but there is now what I would
refer to as a center of mass of data
that point to the fact that psilocybin
when taken in the appropriate set and
setting at the appropriate dosages
can invoke the sorts of neuroplasticity
and changes in emotionality in
perceptual experience not just during
the Psychedelic session but for long
periods of time after the Psychedelic
session that can provide really
remarkable relief from things like major
depression and perhaps other psychiatric
issues as well and of course I realize
that many of you are listening to and
are watching this episode and you're not
necessarily depressed or thinking about
psychedelics like psilocybin in the
context of depression I hope today's
discussion allowed you to better
understand how psychedelics
and psilocybin in particular because
that's what we've been talking about
are able to exert these incredible
effects that they seem to exert
this is not a call for everyone to run
out and do psilocybin it is absolutely
not that it is however my attempt to
really put a magnifying lens on this
incredible area of research that's
happening not just in the context of
clinical trials but in the context of
trying to understand how serotonin and
how drugs like psilocybin which in many
ways mimic serotonin and more
particularly the activation of
particular receptors in the brain like
the serotonin 2A receptor I mean just
sit back and think about that the
selective activation of this receptor
which is by the way associated with the
expansion of the neocortex across
Evolution didn't mention that before but
indeed it is how that can lead to
enhanced ways of thinking changed ways
of thinking actual learning inside of
this short four hour or six hour session
that we call the psilocybin Journey so
as is often the case perhaps as is
always the case here on the huberman Lab
podcast we did a deep dive into a topic
today into the topic of psilocybin what
it is how it works
the different ways in which changes
brain circuitry how it creates the
experiences that we think of as the
psilocybin Journey what the safety
issues are
what the so-called set and setting are
that can lend themselves to positive
therapeutic outcomes and in doing so my
goal was really to highlight several
things first of all I am very excited
about the potential for
psychedelics such as psilocybin to
provide relief for mental health issues
that to date have been very hard for
people to access in addition to that I'm
just fundamentally interested in the
brain and how it works and how it can
change this thing we call
neuroplasticity to me neuroplasticity is
the Holy Grail of the human nervous
system as far as we know we are the
animal that can have long lasting
neuroplasticity throughout the lifespan
and if it requires the use of compounds
in a safe and controlled way such as
psilocybin in order to achieve maximal
plasticity in a short amount of time
that's exciting but of course that also
needs to be considered with all of the
safety precautions in mind that we
talked about earlier including the fact
that people who have a predisposition or
who have psychosis or bipolar disorder
or a relative that has psychosis or
bipolar disorder younger people meaning
people 25 years of age and younger and
really anyone who's not working with a
dedicated and highly trained physician
needs to be very cautious about these
com pounds as well they're very exciting
I think psilocybin is an exciting and
super interesting compound for basic and
clinical reasons and for other reasons
as well but
they are sharp blades as we say and with
sharp blades you can do incredible
things but you can also cut yourself
very badly so all those considerations
need to be taken to mind so I consider
the science and use of psilocybin to be
an exciting but still preliminary area
that I certainly am paying a lot of
attention to and I know there's a lot of
excitement about so stay tuned for the
episode with Dr Robin carder Harris and
we will probably revisit psilocybin and
we will certainly revisit the other
psychedelics and non-classical
psychedelics including LSD DMT 5meo DMT
ketamine MDMA mescaline and all the rest
in future episodes as well if you're
learning from and are enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's the best zero cost way to
support us in addition please subscribe
to the podcast on both apple and Spotify
and on both apple and Spotify you can
also leave us up to a five-star review
if you have questions for me or comments
about this or any other podcasts or
topics that you'd like me to cover or
guess you would like me to interview on
the government Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments in addition
please check out the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning and throughout today's
episode that's the best way to support
this podcast not so much during today's
episode but on many previous episodes of
the human Lab podcast we talk about
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people do
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing the quality and
duration of their sleep for things like
improving focus and for hormone
augmentation and much more the uberman
Lab podcast is proud to have partnered
with momentous supplements if you'd like
to learn more about the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so livemomentis.com huberman if you
haven't already subscribed to our
huberman Lab podcast neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a completely zero cost newsletter
that includes summaries of podcast
episodes and summaries of protocols
things like a tool kit for improving
your sleep a tool kit for improving
Focus toolkit for neuroplasticity
toolkit related to deliberate cold or
deliberate heat exposure to Fitness to
flexibility and much more again all zero
cost simply go to hubermanlab.com go to
the menu scroll down to newsletter and
provide your email we do not share your
email with anybody and again the
newsletter is completely zero cost and
to see previous newsletters you can
simply scroll down a bit further on that
neural network newsletter page at
hubermanlab.com and you'll find
downloadable PDFs and you can just click
on any of those PDFs no sign up required
and if you're not already following me
on social media it's hubermanlab on
Instagram Twitter Facebook and Linkedin
and on all those places I discuss
science and science related tools some
of which overlaps with the content of
the huberman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from the content
covered here on the huberman Lab podcast
so again it's huberman lab on Instagram
Facebook Twitter and Linkedin thank you
once again for joining me for today's
discussion all about psilocybin and last
but certainly not least thank you for
your interest in science
thank you